prince harry is showing us that
age is just a number
over the weekend the duke of cambridge
and his wife kate middleton
took a visit to queen bay lodge a
nursing home in scotland
in an effort to support community
innovation and social enterprise during
the pandemic
and prince william did just that eating
ice cream and bonding
with this lucky resident
all jokes aside prince william was happy
to play along and also raise awareness
via instagram
reminding his followers at the elderly
home is operated by crossreach
which supports over 10 000 people in
scotland living in challenging
situations especially during cobit 19.
the duke and duchess have been very
vocal on assisting those who have been
closely affected by the pandemic
the experiences the frontline workers
are going through now is like nothing
that anyone
has ever seen i i would believe a lot of
them are
getting on with the job and making us
all very proud
by how they're just their stoicism and
their determination to beat this
it's really a family interest as
william's brother prince harry
recently took the stage at the vax live
benefit concert
pushing others to offer empathy to
others struggling during the pandemic
in reality and especially with this
pandemic
when any suffer we all suffer
we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy
and compassion for those we know and
those we don't
we need to lift up all of humanity and
make sure
that no personal community is left
behind
and aside from the royal family helping
others we'll soon be seeing a more
playful side of william and kate
earlier this month the couple announced
they'll be launching their own
youtube channel by the way you'll be
careful what you say now because these
guys they're filming
royal expert katie nicholl dished to et
about the motivation behind william and
kate's new venture
the youtube channel is obviously an
important medium for the cambridges and
up until now they've shared that
platform with the royal family so i
think it's quite significant that we've
seen them
branch away set up their own channel and
given the emphasis that they are now
putting on social media
on videos this is really important for
them we're covering the royal family in
a very different way today that's
largely down to the pandemic
we don't cover engagements the way we
used to we simply can't
have many of us on the ground covering
these engagements
so we're very dependent on the royals to
cover their engagements
and what they're up to i think this is
very important for the cambridges to
reach out to a
a new demographic uh essentially a
younger audience they
realize the value of streaming they've
got a brilliant digital
team behind them we've seen more of them
i think at home
relax in their own time during the
pandemic
through video conference calls and
videos that they've chosen to release
i think we'll see more of that
[Music]